hey youtubers is Charlie so the actor
that plays eddie thawne confirmed he's
coming back to the show so we gotta
break this down he didn't say exactly
which episode he's gonna come back for
but there a couple of theories about
what's gonna be going on and why they're
bringing him back now so I'll say new
round of the flash ring giveaway starts
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video
winners are usually announced at the end
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts that you don't miss anything so
many things going on here so we'll talk
about who he might be how they might use
him in the future
and why they're bringing him back now so
they always bring the big characters
back but number five I think the biggest
reason they're bringing him back is just
sort of a wink at the fans and trying to
fix the character just a little bit
because he started out in season 1 when
they first teased him and they explained
what his name was everyone's like oh my
god what's what's going on here he was
one of those things where they take a
name from a really big character like
the biggest character from the Flash's
villains gallery and then sort of paired
that with the character that you've
never heard of with a backstory that's
unfamiliar so Eddie Thawne is not
somebody from the comics but they hadn't
explained that the reverse-flash was
gonna be the big villain eobard thawne
so this was just meant to show you that
he could go in any different direction
sort of like storm clouds on the horizon
like oh something's gonna be happening
with his character but what ended up
happening is kind of unfortunate because
he ended up getting sidelined in this
melodrama plot where he and Barry were
competing for irises affections I don't
think the dudes that were watching the
show were very happy about this and I
don't think that the iris fans that were
watching were happy about it either
because she didn't really have anything
to do during season 1 other than be the
object of affection like she was the
prize that was won by either Barry or
Eddie
so rewind back to the first half of the
season they do provide some context for
iris as character how she grew up with
Barry how she was so important to him
but she really didn't exist without
barrier without Eddie's storyline so I
think everybody was just really
unsatisfied with the way that ended up
happening so they wanted to fix that in
the back half of the season so they
completely changed with
original plans were for the characters
so number four what was that original
eddie thawne plan like what were they
originally gonna do with the character
before they decided to kill him off
because Andrew Kreisberg the showrunner
said that originally they had something
totally different in mind
they weren't gonna kill him but when
they did you saw hyung get sucked up
into the singularity with the talisman
on so he got to be the hero but they
sort of like teased that something
really big was going to be happening
later on at season 2 like who they're
very clearly setting something up
comic-book rules if there's no body then
he's not dead so originally a lot of
people had theories that Eddie Thawne
would be the season 2 villain because
his character had hunter zolomon
backstory from the comics with a Thawne
name so people are like ooh maybe he's
gonna be the zoom of season 2 he'll be
like the big bat because Barry stole his
girlfriend so in explaining it that way
you kind of see the problem with that
like they didn't want to turn iris into
the object of affection in that way so I
think they just pivoted their plans but
originally I think their plan was is to
make Eddie more of a season 2 villain
person in the way that arrow did the
same thing with Slade Wilson in the
first two seasons so if you didn't watch
arrow what happened in the first season
is that you meet Slade Wilson in anybody
that reads comics was like oh my god
this is Deathstroke and he's friends
with Oliver on the island what's going
on here this is so crazy where are they
gonna take this season two that plays
out he becomes the Deathstroke character
and it became one of the best seasons of
arrow ever so because the same people
that make arrow started making the flash
it sounded like they were sort of
repeating that paradigm but then about
halfway through decided to pivot and
double down on the Jay Garrick storyline
set that up and make him more of a thing
in season 2 during season 2 they took
actual hunter zolomon and sort of paired
that with the Jay Garrick storyline in
it as much as that made people upset
like longtime comic book readers are
like oh my god you're telling us the Jay
Garrick is evil so before the big twist
at the end where they reveal that it's
actually secretly hunter zolomon that's
been pretending to be Jay Garrick people
were really upset even longtime flash
comic book riot
Mark Waid who the flash TV show borrows
a lot of stuff from was really upset
before they explained the twist it was
this big thing but people get upset at
TV shows all the time so it was kind of
funny watching you know like old comic
book writers shake their fists and stuff
so I actually think that the show chose
the lesser of two evils
you know they chose to not recycle the
Deathstroke arc from arrow but in doing
so they kind of threw themselves into
like this big Jay Garrick twist that
played out like relatively okay could
have been a lot better but number three
the other logic problem I get so many
questions about this if Eddie Thawne
died at the end of season 1 the
reverse-flash of that moment was erased
from existence how did he come back
alive and well during season 2 so this
gets into time travel rules one of the
problems with sci-fi TV shows is that
sometimes you have an actor or a
character or like or a storyline that
just has so much chemistry and works so
well that you want to find a way to
capitalize on that later on but if
they're dead you have to find a way to
explain how they came back so the beauty
of the reverse-flash is that he is
basically the smartest person in this
universe maybe next to Jesse quick like
the way they tease Jesse quick is that
she's smarter than Harrison wells from
earth-2 so one of my favorite lines from
him during season one is when he
actually says I'm a genius where I come
from
imagine what that makes me here so
because of the way he exists in flash
cannon is like the biggest villain that
Barry has ever had ever will have is
that he's sort of the valta Mort and has
Horcruxes plans in case he dies so
because he's a time traveler Doctor Who
style there's a lot of different
versions of him that overlap traveling
through time trying to get rid of Barry
Allen or bring some evil plan to
fruition so even just on earth one in
our universe there are multiple versions
of eobard thawne's that are all aware of
each other like he understands time
travel like no one else when you mess
with time travel we learned during
season two the time wraiths will come
for you
the reverse-flash is one of the few
people that knows how to keep off their
radar so he's able to time travel in a
way that the other flashes aren't but
the simplest
explanation for how a bar thawne is
still alive after Eddie killed himself
is one because of Flashpoint now but two
because of a speed force protective
bubble like a Speed Force Horcrux so
even if you haven't read the comics
earlier this season Jay Garrick
explained that the Speed Force is sort
of a nexus of space-time it exists out
of normal space-time so if a younger
version of the reverse flash is
traveling back through the Speed Force
when older reverse flash gets killed
then the Speed Force protects that
younger version from the consequences of
Eddie's death so as of season two that's
really the only way that Eddie can still
be dead in the reverse-flash on earth
one can still be alive because number
two you know which version of Eddie is
this gonna be so like I said flashpoint
happened this season they could choose
to bring back Eddie via flashpoint but I
feel like that creates more problems
than it's worth then you have to explain
why he's not around all the time on
earth one the easier explanation is that
it's earth to Eddie who we learned
during season 2 is alive and well
based on Barry's phone they're still
friends we have no idea how different he
is they just teased his name like Oh
Barry talks to him on a regular basis
he's on his speed dial so clearly
they're friends he's doing well this is
great so this season they will be going
back to earth to eventually so that'd be
my first vote is that when they go back
to earth - they'll just find a way for
Eddie to show up but you guys can let me
know which version of Eddie you want
them to use I just feel like the Jesse
quake is a really good example of why
multiverse characters are the best way
to explain why people aren't around so
Jesse quick is the flash of earth - they
have all the same types of problems that
they have on earth one maybe nots avatar
level problems but they still have
villains running amok so team flash on
earth - does the exact same thing the
team flash on earth one does so she's
very very busy so she can't just come
over and hang out all the time and the
other thing about earth two or three you
know multiverse characters is part of
the fun is that you get to learn how
their life is different and what's
different about them are they a villain
on a different earth we can learn about
all
the adventures that they had that we
didn't get to see because it was in a
different universe so number one though
what about turning Eddie into a villain
or a speedster in a future season like
cobalt-blue style doing something really
crazy some big twist with him
the original plotline of season 1 to
season 2 like I said sounded like they
wanted to do that with him use him as
more of the hunter zolomon zoom
character turned that twist from the
comics into a big thing so in the comics
hunter zolomon is a police detective
that works with the Wally West character
inside the Central City Police
Department Gorilla Grodd attacks the
city his spine is broken so he can't
walk anymore
in Wally refuses to go back in time to
change it so in his grief hunter zolomon
tries to use the cosmic treadmill to fix
it himself gets into an accident and it
gives him powers turning him into the
zoom character so that's comic book zoom
TV zoom was like a completely separate
thing so I don't think they're gonna do
that but I do think it's totally
possible they could pick one of the
other lesser speedsters to make Eddie
Thawne some future villain or it's like
a small twist but I feel like if they
did that it would be like the rival he'd
be around for a couple episodes it would
be like a really small thing he wouldn't
be the main villain let me know if they
bring Eddie back and turn him into a
villain in a future season which
character do you want him to be what's
gonna happen next is that unless they
dropped some footage I'm gonna be doing
a legion trailer video it's basically
x-men Breaking Bad for the most powerful
x-men character ever it's a new TV show
that's gonna be on FX networks in the
United States it's gonna simulcast
internationally on Fox channels so I'll
explain when I post that trailer video
but that's gonna be a Thursday show
going forward so I almost forgot
congratulations to the new reverse flash
ring giveaway winner Kieran Owens be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details I will be doing
giveaways for the Legion TV show so I'll
explain when I post that later today
while you wait for that you can click
here to watch the trailer for the next
episode of the flash and you can click
here for my Star Wars episode
evil ray theory thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight